[Music]
foreign
security gig
hello
welcome to Freddy's have you met them
yet
who
foxy Bonnie Chica Freddy
back in the 80s
some kids went missing what is this
that's why the place shut down
can we search Freddy's hey they never
found the kids
[Music]
ghost children
possessing giant robots tell me how to
stop them
you don't it's too late
he's coming
[Music]
hi this is Mike I was just calling to
see if that job that you offered was
still available yes
security guard I will take anything
this place was huge in the 80s with the
kids they shut it down years ago the
owners just not ready to let it go yet
I will work and you will sleep I
understand
all you have to do is keep your eyes on
the monitor
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's where
fantasy and fun come to life okay
[Music]
[Applause]
we must be new security guard can I uh
help you officer have you met them yet
[Applause]
then
[Music]
in the 80s kids went missing
the police searched Freddy's top to
bottom hello
they never found them
that's why the play shut down
there are ghost children possessing
giant robots
thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics
what do they want they want to make her
like them Bobby
tell me how to stop them
too late
where to
why do I always get the weirdos
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria
where fantasy and fun come to life hit
it guys
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're watching this video
it means you've been selected as
Freddy's newest security guard
hello
we're going to have so much fun together
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]